j'ai peut-être un tour de magie une fois
mais je ne raterai pas deux fois aux
gays regardez bien ces débats ne va
jamais raté rire voilà vous pouvez
attendre longtemps cherché passard
atterrira pas bon alors on achète on est
bon les amis aujourd'hui on va parler
d'une théorie qui est génial je l'aimais
cela j'en ai entendu parler beaucoup de
fois en plus de ça et c'est bien de la
merde
non c'est pas de la merde il est vrai on
peut y croire on peut ne pas y croire
mais je pense qu'il est plus facile de
ne pas y croire que d'y croire mais on y
va dans cette histoire on va parler un
petit peu des cils bennati tout le monde
connaît les illuminati il nous
gouvernent en secret il contrôle les
médias aujourd'hui pas parler d une
nature générale mais on va parler d'une
branche spécifique des illuminati la
branche du clonage
j'adore faire ce genre de vidéos vous
avez sûrement peut-être vu sur le net
beyoncé serait mort dans un accident et
un clown la remplacerait avril la vie ne
paraît et paul mccartney aussi pourquoi
les illuminati irait clooney des genres
pourquoi laissez moi vous parler de
donald marshall ou plutôt du ski 10 en
2011 il a publié un énorme post sur
facebook qui a fait un buzz total dans
ce long pavés il dévoile être lui-même
un clown wallonne almarcha tu commences
viens-tu vous intéresse fort raconte un
peu la suite parce que on a envie d'y
croire à ton histoire il a eu la
malchance de se retrouver dans une
station de clonage dirigé par qui
parking la reine elizabeth ii marche
alors été vendus aux illuminati par ses
parents qui étaient en baisse quand il
avait l'âge de 5 ans certains deviennent
serveurs pour arrondir leurs fins de
mois d'autres vendent leurs enfants aux
illuminati ces bons selon marshall les
illuminati se rencontrent généralement
dans des bunkers souterrains et toujours
selon marshall et à certains bunkers qui
cache des fermes
a clown qui sont et qui apporte
énormément d'argent parce qu'apparemment
faire un clown ça coûte de l'argent
le délire du clonage aurait commencé peu
de temps après la seconde guerre
mondiale quand les hommes politiques ont
commencé à s'afficher avec des stars que
ce soit du cinéma ou de la musique star
qu'il pouvait contrôler puisque ce sont
des clones sauf qu'ils se souviennent
pas d'être des clones dont qui sont très
dociles schéma si vous avez vu le film
cyrille lehn mais par exemple dans le
film ils utilisent les clones en fait
les gens riches se font clooney pour
qu'ils aient un problème est qu'ils
aient besoin d'une greffe ou quoi eh ben
ils le prennent à leurs clones en fait
voilà une sorte de sécurité souci une
assurance vie jusque là se tient un peu
c'est là où ça part un peu en couille où
notre ami marchal a testé un cocktail
expérimental de toutes les drogues
réunis et la cus principalement à la
famille royale d'angleterre 2
partis du coup apparemment elisabeth
serait l'une des pires est leur frais
des trucs affreux comme par exemple les
découper à l'épée pendant qu'ils hurlent
vous commencez un peu moins aimé donald
marshall a est respectée le hockey c'est
le premier clown qui a réussi à s'enfuir
du complexe des illuminati ok on lui
doit le respect c'est un [ __ ] de héros
ce mec comme il l'a fait d'ailleurs pour
réussir à s'enfuir
il a dû établir le meilleur plan de
l'histoire un truc infaillible des
illuminati ont eu peur de sa puissance
il est si mal à donald marshall
il a chanté c'est bon il a chance et lui
qu'il le dise je n'invente rien donald
marshall aurait chanté comme ça devant
les illuminati et enfin il aurait
chanter des trucs qu'il a composé
lui-même et les illuminati aurait adoré
ces musées qu'ils auraient donc arrêter
de maltraiter le pauvre donald et aurait
préféré tirer profit de son talent pour
la musique est respectée loin il aurait
composé single ladies de beyoncé
unforgiven de metallica you're gonna go
far qui désirent free et charlie d'armes
de pitbull bon salon semblait que j'aime
c'est ainsi que donald marshall regagne
sa liberté et n'est plus prisonnier des
illuminati il a fait des interviews il a
été contacté par énormément de personnes
il a même une fanbase qui lui a créé un
site
alors c'est quoi la suite lucas plus
tard calmez vous votre star et peut-être
morte il ya de nombreuses années mais
les illuminati vont remplacer par un
clown ou par un sosie et vous n'y avez
vu que du feu
je vous propose d'enquêter sur ces stars
qui aurait été remplacé il ya des années
par un clown puisqu'elle serait en
réalité morte
premièrement avril lavigne commence à
personne et fan d'elle en 2018 avril
lavigne se serait suicidé en 2003 après
que ses parents est divorcée les mecs
vous aurais pas pu trouver meilleure
raison quand même elle aurait été
remplacé par un sosie du nom
maëlys alors pourquoi chercher un sosie
quand tu peux faire des clonages je sais
pas mais bon mais qu'est-ce qui a trahi
mais nice a alors qu'elle lui ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau et ban après
les fans c'est son nez effectivement le
nez 2 avril est différent du nez de
mélissa c'est surtout la photo qui est
différente
il y en a une de face ou de profil une
les couleurs sont pas aux flottes les
couleurs sont hyper lumineuse il aurait
aussi trouvé suspecte dans une des
chansons de mélissa du coup après la
mort 2 avril viennent ligne qu'ils
disent
[Musique]
ayez
cela
wes de thé
la femme
le ser
[ __ ] mais c'est sur elles par david
c'est sûr elle parle du jour avril est
morte et qu'elle a su qu'elle allait
devoir prendre la place ou alors elle
parle de son chien culés les fans ont
aussi trouvé une interview suspecte
d'avril lavigne au brésil où ses
réponses aux questions d'une journaliste
qui croient à cette théorie sont un peu
bizarres avoir swinging conteuse on voit
clairement le tournage tu parles tu peux
pas dire je n'ai pas entendu parler
alors que c'est un buzz total depuis des
années ce qui est bon signe
[Musique]
mme avril de réaction est étrange mais
peut-être est-ce la réaction normale
quand la journaliste dit que tu est un
clown alors que c'est toi bon sens et
tout pour avril ou devrais je dire
mélissa on passe à quelqu'un d'autre
tiens ça m'a saoulé ok on passe à eminem
eminem dans les années 90 après le boss
total de son album scream cherry aurait
été approché par les illuminati comme
bon nombre de stars après un boss total
mais il aurait refusé ils auraient
décliné leur offre un an
les illuminati l'aurait donc tué dans un
accident de voiture c'est souvent ça en
plus c'est souvent un accident de
voiture et il l'aurait remplacé par un
clown cette fois voyons voir ces
différences à la courbe de ses cheveux
aurait changé bah comme pour beaucoup
d'hommes à quand tu vieillis oui la
courbe de tes cheveux change un peu je
suis désolé d'avoir rappelé que votre
calvitie et est bien réelle
et pourquoi ils ont trouvé l'oreille
l'oreille est différent à temps et
clermont pareil cas il ya des gros labos
en plus et mesdames hockey à je
comprends pas l'argument là c'est quoi
c'est l'espace entre le sourcil et les
cheveux c'est ça c'est même pas ça me
fatigue attention alerte les clowns des
fois on avait les bugs et apparemment le
clown d'eminem rue un bug en plein live
à la télé le 7 septembre 2013 ou le 9
juillet 2013 c'est peut-être la date en
américain je sais pas il est éclaté mon
gars jean-luc il est là
là c'est le pire truc qui peut t'arriver
en live à la télé ensuite il passe un
peu des extraits de ces sons et quand
c'est résolu je vais régler ce qui est
normal ou war was all à la souris est-ce
que c'est bel et bien un clown qui a
buggé ou alors est ce que c'est juste
eminem qui a décidé de prendre un peu de
drogue 1 avant cette interview et cette
soirée géniale
on ne sait pas ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'il a remis ça y'a pas si longtemps
dans une autre interview je sais pas si
tu te relâches cette fois ci mais ils
étaient encore une fois dans une
interview il ya un problème avec les
interviews je crois ça fait bugger savon
de ménage et il a eu une phase
exactement comme celle qu'on a vue avant
qe3
o les chiites
j'avoue là c'est quand même creepy sur
tout ce qui est écrit pisser après avoir
fait sa phase là il n'a pas fait un
petit chemin dans votre à ce que j'ai
fait c'est un peu drôle et où il garde
son sérieux de look
ici rien d'alarmant une petite blague
d'eminem ou un petit rail de quelque
chose avant alors attends à la j'aime
bien celle là elle est bien
connaissez-vous les beatles se célèbre
groupe anglais comme une isabelle 2
[Musique]
c'est par hasard ça ils ont fait danser
nos parents et les ont faits qui fait
c'étaient des modèles monga des
superstars mais apparemment paul
mccartney serait mort dans un accident
de voiture encore en 1966 c'est la
rumeur qui circulait à londres à cette
époque sauf que paul mccartney en 2018
est toujours bel et bien aux vies alors
la formation c'est delfosse ou
s'est-elle vrai paul mccartney aurait
été remplacé par un sosie et non pas un
clown apparemment ce serait le mi5 le
service de renseignements britannique
qui aurait imposé aux labels de
remplacer par mccartney par un sosie
pour éviter de nombreux suscite chez les
fans des beatles
j'avoue ça paraît logique que ce soit le
label des beatles qui soit dit en citant
et génère vraiment énormément d'argent
si lui il est mort c'est au loup quand
même on va peut-être en mettre un autre
comme ça ça continue à faire de la thune
la rumeur prend beaucoup d'importance
après la sortie de l'album abbey road en
69 parce que sur la pochette du disque
la configuration de la scène regorgerait
de preuves montrant que paul mccartney
serait mort attention déjà lui les pieds
nus comme les personnes enterrées en
inde
à côté de lui et ringo starr et habillés
en noir qui est la couleur de la mort en
occident
john lennon quant à lui est habillé en
blanc qui est la couleur de la mort en
oriente mec justice à billes en noir en
blanc parce que c'est cool ce style est
quoi george harrison ferme la marche et
son jean témoignerait du fait qu'il
s'est chargé de la mise en terre
il est le seul à ne pas marcher du même
pas il tient également une cigarette
dans la main droite alors qu'il est
gaucher
peut-être parce qu'ils ont choisi le
profil droit pour faire leurs photos etc
si la tenue en main gauche elle ne se
voyait pas peut-être après le ballon ça
je veux pas faire de deux dramas de plus
la plaque d'immatriculation de la
voiture en arrière-plan lmw 28f
signifierait levings mccartney would be
toualy eight if paul mccartney vivant
aurait 28 ans il est au fond à droite le
vans sombre serait un corbillard a
franchement elle est pas mal celle là
quand même ça va loin j'aime bien
certains fans auraient même entendu john
lennon dire aïe bahreïn qui veut dire
j'ai enterré paul dans la dernière
partie du sourd strawberry fields
forever
john lennon s'est expliqué en disant
qu'il n'a pas dit à brad boyes mais
qu'il a dit cranberries sauce
ce qui n'a vraiment rien à voir les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur les
illuminati et le clonage j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu j'avoue j'aime
bien la théorie d'une des stars sont
décédées alors on les remplace par des
soucis ni vu ni connu comme si elle
continue de faire de l'argent maintenant
pourquoi des stars ont été remplacés par
des clones et pourquoi tout non alors
qu'elle faisait elle aussi énormément
d'argent je sais pas moi
michael jackson tupac amy winehouse du
coup juste ça ça suffit à discréditer
toute cette thèse du des clones et des
sosies mais bon c'est quand même rigolo
et ça se trouve à moi aussi je suis un
clown à la tri dans une prochaine vidéo
pour parler d'autres théories j'en ai
tout sous la main que je qui j'ai 3 2
tout ça je fais des bisous a très vite
[Musique]